in this video we'll talk about the
process of valerian degeneration
Valerian degeneration is also known as
injury-induced neurodegeneration and it
is defined by the degeneration of the
Axon
in the distal site of the nerve injury
it is further characterized by
disintegration of cytoskeleton
underlying the axon mitochondrial
swelling and axon fragmentation
this phenomena was initially reported by
Augustus Waller and based on his name it
was known as Valerian degeneration it
was discovered 1850 but until
20th century scientists have a deeper
understanding about the molecular
mechanism so in this video we'll talk
about the molecular mechanism but before
that let me tell you we all experience
some sort of nerve injury sometimes
maybe you are compressing your nerves by
sleeping on your hands and you all felt
that tingling sensation on your nerve
and this is due to compression this is a
most mild form of injury sometimes
injury is more serious like let's say
somebody fail badly in from in a bike
accident
and in that case there could be a
severing of a part of their motor or
axon let's say so that could be a more
severe form of injury
so in case of severe nerve injury
the region which is distal to the injury
site can disintegrate over time and
that's the overall principle of valerian
degeneration any injury or
disintegration of the nerve fibers
in the distal site of injury site
so question is what really happens in
the Valyrian degeneration how these
axons are disintegrating what goes wrong
is it simple new programmed cell death
or it is different from the program cell
death
an Insight came from a mouse mutant
known as
wlds or Valerian degeneration slow
in normal circumstances after the injury
the distal site of the injury site will
eventually be disintegrated and the
interneuron would die in some days
but in Valerian degeneration slow mutant
the entire process of degeneration is
much slower note that the degeneration
happens but at a slower time scale
scientists wondered what really happens
in this mouse mutant that makes this
degeneration slow
imagine in this way that if scientists
understand what makes the
process slower in this mutant they can
devise any therapeutic Target or drug to
slow down this kind of injury process
but before understanding that we have to
understand
what is so special about the
basically world is Mouse
so basically
there is a important cellular process
that we have to understand the cell Soma
of any neuron produce an enzyme known as
nmna T2
this enzyme catalyze the conversion of
nmn or nicotinamide mononucleotide into
NAD
and it happens by a series of
biochemical reaction so we are just
simply saying this is a transferase
enzyme that converts nmn to NAD
this process is important because NAD is
required in ETC it would be required to
produce ATP so from a neuronal
functionality point of view
this NAD generation is super important
nmna T2 is very short-lived enzyme that
means it has to be produced continuously
by the cell body and can have to be
transported to the axons so this axonal
transport of Soma derived nmn82 is super
important for neuronal functionality
now imagine a situation when there is a
injury in the Axon
the nmna t2 cannot reach the synaptic
terminal because already there is a path
break right
so in the synaptic terminal there would
be no conversion of nmn into NAD
and these kind of cellular deprivation
of NAD would lead to several problems
from an energy point of view
not only NAD is reduced but the overall
cytosolic concentration of nmn is
increased both these things might lead
to changes
so it turns out that nmn buildup is
actually toxic for the neurons
because
in Wild Ace it has been shown that there
is a so what is wild Ace actually in
retrospect let me tell you Wireless is
one of the stably axonal targeted NM
nat2 enzyme so this enzyme is more
targeted towards the axon in this
particular mutant that means even if
there is a degeneration since these
while proteins are more targeted toward
the axon even after degeneration there
is significant amount of an immunity to
present in the axonal terminal that can
still lead to the native biogenesis
so
this is the normal scenario this is the
wildest scenario and scientists also
have blocked
specific Pathways that lead to the
biosynthesis of nmn and they found out
that the axonal degeneration is also
slower
that means nmn is the main culprit
if nmn accumulates in the neuron or
somehow
there is a overall increase in the cyto
solic concentration of nmn that might
lead to several problem or that might
aggravate the process of degeneration
because in a mutant where animal could
not build up quickly or in a
pharmacological scenario when you block
the element biosynthesis both the cases
there is a protection against this
neurodegeneration or Valyrian
degeneration
so that brings out the important role of
nmn in
axonal degeneration process
now there is another molecule which
works in coordination with nmnity 2
pathway
so this particular molecule is known as
sum 1.
this molecule is a immune molecule and
it has a
it has involvement in the interleukin
signaling pathway
so it has been shown that someone
mutants just like the wildest mutant
shows a slow degeneration kinetics that
means somehow these mutant phenocopies
the wildest mutants
so question is why the slow digestion is
happening in retrospect lot of Pathways
and molecular interaction tells us the
overall scenario
so it turns out that either element
degeneration can happen so the enemy T2
can be degraded quickly the delivery of
n amenity 2 can be disrupted due to a
loss in lags on there could be rapid
turnover of nmnity 2 due to map K
pathway all these signal all these three
events lead to
loss of the enzyme nmnat2 now once this
enzyme is lost we can completely
understand nmn would build up because
the conversion of NM into NAD doesn't
happen when the enzyme is not there
and scientist has pinpointed that nmn
accumulation or elevation in the neurons
are toxic
this would actually lead to someone
activation
in a mechanism which is not fully
understood but someone works like a
executor caspase it's important to note
that the Valerian degeneration actually
kills the neuron but it's not exactly
like a apoptosis pathway anyway someone
activation further changes the calcium
level in the neurons when the calcium
levels are elevated it lead to kalpin
activation and lead to the damage of the
neurons
and this is how the Valerian
degeneration takes place so you
understood the overall mechanism that
are involved in the Valerian
degeneration process two important
components are nmn82 and the sound one
sarmon is the executor molecule in this
entire degeneration process
now let's see why it is important
clinically
it turns out that an immunity to protein
and mRNA levels are reduced in the brain
of Alzheimer patient
and think about this way alzheimeration
has increased susceptibility to
neurodegeneration so overall nmn82 and
nmn concentration in neurons are kind of
implicated with neurodegenerative
scenarios like Alzheimer's disease
so genome-wide Association studies has
pointed out Psalm 1 Locus is associated
with ALS or amyastropic lateral
sclerosis where the motor neurons
degenerate
also other diseases like fetal echinacea
deformation syndrome in this case nma T2
loss of function situation has been
identified
so somehow we can understand several
neurodegenerative disease are well
associated with nmn82 level or Psalm 1
level so that brings out it's important
in context of several neurodegenerative
disorders
now I have a detailed video on types of
nerve injury including neuropraxia exome
exonautomesis and neurotomasis you can
watch that video by clicking on the link
which is provided in the description or
in the I button I hope this video was
informative and medically relevant if
you like this video don't forget to
follow us on Facebook page or Instagram
page support our Channel using super
thanks you can pay via paytm PayPal or
UPI see you in next video
[Applause]
all right